so continuing to work through questions
this one got asked and actually i was
gonna skip it but uh it does still come
up
and that is uh my name and what to call
me now i did kind of a little video
uh laying out my pronouns that i no
longer use he him
and it's either she or they either one's
fine now
if you go to my live streams or whatnot
most people at this point will refer to
me as
vera but if you stick around through the
end credits
of any given video you will see
nathaniel
nathaniel's also the name is going to
appear on my book when that releases in
june
so they're both still perfectly viable
now i can't account for why people
prefer to go with one or the other if i
were to hazard a guess
i would think it probably throws some
people off to use
she or they for a distinctly masculine
name like nathaniel whereas
vera for someone who looks like me maybe
they can roll with a a lot of people
who've gone with she
i suspect that's how that pans out but
for me either one works